Welcome back everyone this will be my brand
new marvel nova video they're finally doing
a nova project they finally announced it so we'll
break it all down there's a bunch of easter eggs
and a couple avengers infinity war and avengers
end game deleted scenes featuring the character
that you might have heard about so if you're
brand new to the channel we are doing videos for
all the moon knight episodes starting next week so
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and post all your nova reactions on the video
some of you will probably have to wait till after
you watch the video to find out what's going on
but some of you might know what i'm talking
about recently in your feeds you probably saw
the official announcement that marvel is finally
confirmed to be making a nova project with the
showrunner from the moon night series that also
really bodes well for the writing on moon knight
if they brought back that dude to develop their
nova project everyone remembers the russo brothers
talking about nova back when they were promoting
avengers end game a couple years ago macho man
rooster brothers how do you guys not have any
nova court member in a fight against thanos
loved the movie but just boggles my mind didn't
even have to be richard ryder i look closely
at that scene again there and you will see there
are thousands of people yeah you will see richard
ryder in the background of a shot easter egg at
the time we were kind of like what the hell what
are you doing that for russo brothers but now it
makes a little more sense marvel's been trying to
figure out how to do the nova character right for
the last several years since long before avengers
infinity war avengers end game happened in fact
like i said there are a bunch of deleted scenes
from infinity war and end game featuring the
richard ryder character that clip of the russo
brothers talking about the original version of
the character during the final battle of endgame
was just the tip of the iceberg i'll explain
all those deleted scenes with the character
in a second but there is a lot of confusion
over whether marvel is doing a nova movie like
giving him his own traditional solo movie like
you would have seen before disney plus existed
or if they're doing a nova series on disney
plus as is now the tradition in marvel phase 4
mostly some minor characters appear in the movies
for the first time some appear on disney plus now
currently marvel is developing the project
as a limited series on disney plus what that
means though is the limited series is one season
like nova would debut on a disney plus series and
then he'd be in all the movies going forward like
they're not showing the character and then never
bringing him back it's the same with moon knight
moon knight is a limited series but he's showing
up on disney plus first and then he's going to be
crossing over with all the marvel face 4 marvel
phase 5 movies and avengers 5. what that means
though is you basically get a six hour nova movie
like six forty five minute episodes with him using
the same budget as if we were to get a nova movie
all the disney plus shows typically have budgets
around 150 million dollars each of them telling
what would have been a movie in six hours instead
of two and a half hours like they would have
before when there were only movies moon knight
recently is the best example we get six hours
of moon knight origin story instead of two and a
half then he crosses over with werewolf by night
blade kit harrington's black knight character
from the eternals movie and hopefully we
get a midnight suns in the mcu and then he'll
eventually cross over with the new and existing
avengers in avengers 5. so it's basically
the exact same deal with richard ryder nova
you probably saw recently in your feeds also
talking about a mystery titled marvel space
based tv show they're working on well big surprise
that space based tv show is for nova i'll explain
some of the differences between the comic book
version and the mcu version of the character
richard ryder nova is actually a human who started
out living on earth and is chosen by rhomann dey
this character here played by john c reilly in the
first guardians of the galaxy movie even though
they used the character kind of comedically
he was meant to be a version of rhomann dey
peter jason quill from tara raised from youth by
a band of mercenaries called the ravagers what a
bunch of a-holes in the mcu in the guardians of
the galaxy movie nova prime is actually meant to
be glenn close's character who's just the leader
of the nova corps in the comics rhomann dey plays
the last surviving centurion of the nova corps
like the last living receptacle of the nova force
and he selects richard ryder to succeed him taking
all of his powers nova prime he becomes the sole
receptacle for all the power of the nova force
which in the marvel universe was kind of designed
to be like the power cosmic the power cosmic is
the force wielded by galactus that he gives to
all of his heralds like the silver surfer wields
the power cosmic it makes it incredibly powerful
originally the nova force was designed to be
similar to that but it gives richard ryder
a measure of superhuman strength durability speed
stamina all of his senses it gives him a healing
factor it gives him the ability to generate energy
from his body he also becomes the receptacle for
the xandarian world mind which helps him manage
the power of the nova force because it's so vast
in the mcu we saw zandar quite a bit xandarians
are the main race of the nova corps the thanos
destroyed on his way to take the power stone
at the beginning of avengers infinity war
and here's where that deleted scene featuring nova
picks up how they would have originally introduced
him starting an infinity war so in the theatrical
cut at the beginning of avengers infinity war you
see the rest of the thor ragnarok post credit
scene but it's meant to be the second infinity
stone that thanos has come to collect thor loki
heimdall at least staying behind on their ship
with a portion of the other dead ass guardians now
to stall for time so that the others can escape
thanos has already been to zandar to take the
power stone and in the process basically wiped the
entire planet clean with his fleet in the deleted
intro scene what would have happened is they would
have shown an extended introduction version of
thanos attacking xandar and the nova corps to
take the power stone he would have destroyed the
planet killed nova prime glenn close's character
the rest of the nova corps seemingly but after
he leaves with the power stone to go after thor
and loki it was going to be revealed that richard
ryder was the last soul survivor selected by the
xandarian world mind he would have already been in
training with the nova corps he would have been a
junior character but he would have been the sole
survivor of the planet the xandarian world mind
would have identified him as the nearest available
candidate available for the nova force and because
the world mind manages the flow of all nova energy
all across the universe all their tech for all
their empire and everybody else is supposed to be
dead he's the only survivor richard ryder becomes
the single living receptacle for all of that power
then it would have turned into a little bit of an
mcu john wick arc with richard ryder coming for
thanos with all the power of the nova force being
minted as the new nova prime because the events of
avengers infinity war are meant to play out very
quickly like thanos assembling all the infinity
stones as fast as possible the movie would have
been way too short of a time duration for him
to figure everything out so richard ryder would
have come back during the avengers end game final
battle had a much larger scene taking his revenge
on thanos and his army similar to what you saw
from scarlet witch like she kind of shows up in
the final battles you took everything from me and
almost winds up killing thanos richard ryder would
have done something similar so remember how the
russo brothers made that joke about zooming and
enhancing on the final battle and you would see
nova fighting there with all the other characters
that was originally meant to be a joke the way
they presented it in that video he isn't there
in the final battle so don't bother zooming and
enhancing on any of that footage you won't find
him but he was there in the original version of
the scene so technically they weren't wrong like
they were kind of lying but they weren't lying at
the same time he just wasn't in the theatrical cut
what they wound up doing is getting rid of nova in
the infinity war intro scene because they didn't
want to spend an extra 10 minutes explaining who
nova was all of a sudden and this was going to
be the first time you actually met the character
they wanted to get to thanos thor and loki as fast
as possible some familiar characters then when
they were figuring out how they were going to do
avengers end game even though they included every
mcu character in their sister in that final battle
for the most part they didn't want to introduce
nova for the first time as a backup character
for a few seconds that not that many people would
notice on first glance while everybody is flying
at each other on screen and things are going crazy
so they pretty much gave all of his final battle
scenes his entire story arc to captain marvel
and her inclusion was kind of the same deal too
like a left field last minute kind of thing most
of you probably know now watching the behind the
scenes that originally they actually shot footage
of captain marvel for infinity war and end game
way before they ever shot footage for the captain
marvel movie so at the time they hadn't even
figured the character out that's why she looks so
different in those two movies than she does in the
captain marvel movie marvel kind of did that thing
where they're like here's this brand new character
who's super important that we really want you to
care about but we recognize we're just introducing
her right now at the very close of this huge
story about a bunch of other characters that
you actually do care about no matter which way
they went out it was going to be kind of messy in
order to make all those scenes for nova they would
have had to spend way more time during infinity
war setting him up and they really should have
spent a solo movie a couple years before infinity
war setting him up to do it properly so eventually
they got to the point where they made the decision
to introduce him during marvel phase four later
in some space-based plot where they could take
their time and do it properly like you would see
during marvel phase one phase two phase three
cut to now marvel phase four in present day and
that's what's happening because so much of the
nova core is tied to the guardians of the galaxy
movies it is possible that they have a cameo scene
for him during guardians of the galaxy 3 which
they're filming right now that movie is mostly
going to feature adam warlock paying off the post
credit scene from guardians 2 and most likely
a version of the mcu high evolutionary played by
the mern actor from james gunn's peacemaker series
is also possible richard ryder nova gets cut
up in the captain marvel 2 plot the marvels
because aside from the fantastic four movie that
they're working on right now that's the only other
space based movie that they have that they're
developing currently that'll probably change
soon because as you can see in marvel phase 4 even
though multiverse is the operative word right now
like we have doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness coming up in a couple months
marvel phase 4 is also getting way more cosmic and
that's why nick fury is going to space while he's
been in his space station since spider-man no way
home so they'll be doing more and more space-based
disney plus shows more akin to what you see from
the mandalorian episodes in the star wars universe
visiting a bunch of different planets around the
galaxy but mostly traveling around in outer space
let me know in the comments though what do you
think of richard ryder nova finally joining the
mcu officially in which of the marvel phase
4 movies do you want to see him cross over in
i will do videos for the series when we get
more details or a trailer it'll be cool to
see what they wind up doing with them but
congratulations to tret advent you're the
giveaway winner for my last marvel video please
email me on the about page of my channel so i
can get your contact details everyone click
here for that brand new marvel secret invasion
announcement video and click here for my moon
knight episode 1 trailer video and easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!